hi everyone my name's lee ellis and i'm
currently an associate professor in the
department of medicine and scientific
director in the center of urologic
research excellence at the samuel ocean
comprehensive cancer centre at
cedars-sinai medical center in los
angeles i'd like to thank the organizers
of today's forum for allowing me to
speak to you today and share some of our
latest work from the laboratory
so my lab focuses in on prostate cancer
and more so how easy h2 a known
epigenetic regulator involved in
prostate cancer
drives both progression and therapeutic
resistance
now easy h2 uh is the catalytic subunit
of the polycomb repressive complex 2
where it catalyzes the trimethylation
of the k27 or lysine 27 residue of the
histone h3 tail
now functionally this usually causes
gene silencing by the formation of
heterochromatin
but as studies have gone on over the
years we now know that easy h2 along
like other epigenetic
modifiers or these enzymes can actually
target non-histone targets
and some examples here for easy h2 are
listed with stat3
it can also act as a co-activator for
transcription factors like the androgen
receptor or nf kappa b complexes
as well as work in methylation
independent
fashion with
regulating cyclin d and wind target
genes
over the years easy h2 and the polycomb
complex has been shown to be really
important and a master regulator almost
of of multiple biological
uh pathways and and cellular processes
both in developmental biology and cancer
biology and some of those are listed
here and my lab as i said focuses both
in on cell identity and immunity
further
we've also seen the development of these
catalytic inhibitors of easy h2 coming
over the years and they've come to
clinical trials and most recently the
episode compound epz 6438 has just
reached uh and and received fda approval
which is exciting news for the easy age
to
inhibit a field
also within our work you'll see that
i've used a compound tool more for
experimental studies
dz-nep
which is considered a non-catalytic
inhibitor
and so when it comes to prostate cancer
and its overall response to
immunotherapy in the context of
checkpoint blockade therapy
we haven't really been doing so well and
what we're representing here on this
graph
is prostate cancer where it is more
represented by the trials conducted in
the metastatic castration resistance
space
and so here you can see just
demonstrating briefly that firstly we
know that prostate cancer doesn't come
with a lot of somatic mutations or tumor
mutational burden
compared to other cancers such as
melanoma or colorectal cancer
but
we also have a very low overall response
rate when it comes to the clinical trial
outcome just coming in just under 10
percent and so
efforts here from a combination
standpoint are really preceding the
field as to how we can make prostate
cancer more responsive
to immunotherapies or checkpoint
blockade therapies
now the area where my lab is most
concerned is about therapies in the
context of prevention of high-grade um
more aggressive primary prostate cancer
and preventing them from from
progressing to castration resistant
metastatic disease which is often lethal
for the patient
and so
this nice
summary
within this science article a couple of
years ago
uh clearly demonstrates with these two
major parameters of measuring uh the
hotness
of of cancers
both by tumor mutational burden and gene
expression profiling which is more
around an interferon gamma or interferon
signature
otherwise known as a t-cell inflamed
signature
you can see that prostate cancer is
pretty negative for both of these
readouts indicating that especially in
the primary setting that prostate cancer
doesn't have a lot of immunoreactivity
going on and is potentially as i said
one of the coldest landscapes that we're
dealing with in the cancer disease
spectrum
now
another term that i want to introduce to
you here and where our work has led us
is the context of viral mimicry and how
this has been induced by epigenetic
therapy in cancers and i've just put up
a couple of examples here of sort of
leading papers that have have come out
within the
the last couple of years more so the
paper from daniel de cavello up in
toronto that sort of led this field
first publishing in 2015 to sell paper
and and really what these papers
demonstrate to us is that by the use of
epigenetic therapies
that we've been able to modulate or
reprogram the tumor
and also it's tuned a micro environment
to make it more conducive to response to
checkpoint blockade therapy
so when it comes to epigenetic therapy
and it and the induction of viral
mimicry really what i'm explaining and
this is more the story from from our
work there are other versions of this so
this is just not a one size fits all
but basically through the use of
epigenetic therapies in our context easy
h2 inhibition
it results in chromatin modification and
the re-expression of double-strand rna
or repeat elements uh we focus in on a
subset of these double-stranded rna
species known as endogenous retroviruses
and what these double-stranded rna
species will do is
relocate to the cytoplasm where they're
then detected by these sensors
known as
rigai and sting these are the two
examples i'm showing you here
and with that
these sensors then signal usually to to
stat ones or stat heterodimerization
along with
uh dimerization with with earth proteins
to then transcribe interferon stimulated
genes and provide the host with a
defense against what it thinks is a
virus attack
now within these interferon stimulated
genes and just again representing uh
some of the genes that we see and also
other studies
is we get some important uh you know
genes
coming into proteins here where we get
the chemokines
cxcl9 and cxcl11 these are chemo
attractants for t cells
we also get antigen presentation
machinery in the context of beta 2m and
hlaa just two genes shown here
these are important for for mhc class 1
cell presentation of antigen to the
microenvironment and also we get the
breaks of the immune system here where
tumor cells will often express pdl1 to
one evade uh the immune system but also
in
other other forms of immunology these
are also breaks of the system where they
will bind to the t cell receptor pd-1
and ultimately
shut that t-cell down and and make it
exhausted
so really again just what we're seeing
here through this mechanism is up
regulation of immune recognition
of the tumor cell and immune recognition
the context of increased immune
trafficking or the potential to increase
immune trafficking but also
all the increasing the breaks of the
system or immune suppression
so this all started really in the lab
when we were looking
in the context of of easy h2
being a
a synthetic lethal
interaction with the over expression of
mick c mick which is a known driver of
prostate cancer and we thought that if
we could
target easy h2 early it may be a
vulnerability in primary prostate cancer
to ultimately shut it down and make it a
a disease where the patient does not
have to worry about progressing to
metastatic
metastatic state and then dealing with
the
the forms of androgen deprivation that
they'll be treated with and ultimately
coming that therapy resistant lethal
prostate cancer
so what we found and and firstly just
introducing uh the mouse model that we
used where we have the high mix cemic
overexpressed in the prostate cancer
luminal epithelium
and then we introduced fluxed alleles
of easy h2 and basically by using a pro
basin cree recombinase also in in the
mouse
uh we were able to exclusively
uh cut out the set domain of easy h2
making it catalytic dead
ultimately affecting or shutting down
its catalytic function
and so what you can see in organoids
from the mouse here and we also have
this represented in the gems themselves
but we just see the growth over eight
days here of these organoids and then
what we saw was we we saw it more just a
delay of the growth rather than an
actual stoppage uh which was um
ultimately you know
uh surprising and and both sort of
not what we wanted to see um you know
based on our original hypothesis seeing
that this redundancy had come in and
eventually these two these organoids
would regrow and and join their
wild-type counterparts
so we came in at day three
where these growth uh
lines were were quite separated and we
applied rna sequencing to see if we
could uh just sort of see anything that
could indicate
you know an escape route for the for the
uh for these cancers
or these organoids at the time
and so what we found firstly is when we
did both chemical uh inhibition of easy
h2 with dznip or the genetic
modification where this is a tamoxifen
inducible system
so that's why you see tamoxifen here to
elicit the easy h2 catalytic domain
deletion
we can see that we had differentially
expressed genes so genes were going up
and down as we expected but we also had
uh some important uh observations here
where we were getting lots of the the
canonical function of of easy h2 here
both with loss of the k27 trimethyl mark
and also more we were inhibiting the
cells uh by by lowering the edu uh
incorporation into these cells and
this was more of a self-proliferative
inhibition rather than a self-death
mechanism
so
we performed gsea on our rnas
and to our surprise
we enriched for innate immune genes or
basically interferon alpha and
interferon gamma signaling pathways both
in the genetic and the chemical data
sets
we then
used our dz nip work that i'm not
showing here but it is in the paper
using our dc dz nep gene expression data
we could we derived an easy h2 activity
score to where we could then rank
patients based on easy h2 activity
so doing that we then quartile separated
these patients and we compared quartile
one with quartile four the the book ends
uh the highest and the lowest activity
scores
to then do the same analysis through
gene expression and gsa
and just showing you two data sets here
primary data where we have uh
laser captured micro dissected
prostatectomies here from an nci cohort
and also the tcga publicly available
data set and when we did this
again we saw that the
interferon type one and two uh alpha and
gamma signatures
were enriched in the in the nci data set
and and the same for the tcga with gamma
being the most enriched and alpha being
somewhat down but still very significant
so we overlapped
uh both our data sets here from from our
initial mouse experiments just to see
what was shared and what wasn't from a
potential master regulator perspective
and why we had a good number of
interfere on related genes we also had
other drivers
of other processes including
emt
and and some some dna damage
but
first and foremost was the interferon
signaling
so taking into account all of our data
sets that we used and i showed you four
of those the one that we did add here
was a castration resistant cohort
from emission beltran's data these are
just the adenocarcinomas
which
is what's represented here a full
adenocarcinoma data set
and by looking at these and looking for
an overlap of at least three out of five
data sets we derived a 97 gene
set that as you can see is nicely
enriched for for interfere on immune
related genes
now using these 97 genes we then went to
a set of prostatectomies in
collaboration with matt friedman at the
dana farber cancer institute
who had done a lot of epigenetic
profiling within these
within these
patient samples and these samples can be
found in a a recent nature genetics
paper from his lab and we're expecting
these genes just to be really repressed
by
the
enrichment of of a h3k27 trimethyl peak
when we looked at the chipset data and
to to our surprise again
we actually found that these genes were
actually not associated with k27
trimethylation at all indicating that
something else was being directly
affected by the easy h2 inhibition
to
then enrich for these this gene
signature
so other data sets that we're able to
use
from these patients was both
h3 k27 acetylation and also atax
sequencing so k27 acetylation is a mark
of active chromatin or active
transcription and atax sequencing is
when you see a peak uh you
have open chromatin or euchromatin uh
whereas if the peak is not there you
have heterochromatin or the chromatin is
compressed
and
funny enough what we did see here was
that
the majority of our genes were
associated with an active mark k27
acetylation and also open chromatin with
the uh the positive at atac peaks here
that we saw so we were deeming these
genes to actually be primed for
activation rather than repressed and
going through the full chromatin
remodeling mechanism to then activate
them and when you think about these
genes as predominantly being a defense
mechanism uh that that sort of made
sense to us
so coming back to the viral mimicry uh
we we sort of thought that
we we must be inducing viral mimicry to
then um activate indirectly these these
interferon stimulated genes
and so going into two organoid models
here these are our mouse organoids from
the mic model that i showed you
previously and then a human
prostatectomy that we're able to get
within as a short-term culture in in 3d
also in the lab and then treating them
with the two easy h2 inhibitors and
interferon gamma as a control
we showed nicely here that we were able
to up regulate uh
the the double strength the total
cellular double strand rna levels
looking in vivo to where we transplanted
our hymic
2d cell lines in
into mice black six animals here and
then treated with the easy h2 uh
inhibitor we also showed that
this treatment resulted in vivo of an
upregulation of double strand rna
giving us the the context that we were
indeed inducing
double-stranded rna species
at the cellular level and potentially
invoking a mimicry viral mimicry
response
we wanted to sort of prove this a little
bit more and so we went to a data set uh
that was published by steve bulk and
weiwei
that at the time weiwei was was at
beth israel
in boston she's now at ucla and she had
published a story on prostatectomies um
looking at pdl-1
foci and so she had a subset of
prostatectomies here that were either
pdl one high or pdl1 low
and now pdl1 was was it was one of our
interferon uh stimulated genes of
interest
and i'll get to some of that data in a
minute but basically using this data set
and and the the premise of what i was
just talking about we expected to have
an inverse correlation here with both
k27 trimethylation and also
double-strand rna cellular levels and
again these are just untreated uh tissue
so this is just just baseline levels
that we're looking at here
and so what we saw is that in the pdl
one low
tumors and where we expected high k27
with low double strand rna this is what
we exactly saw and then with a pdl one
higher tumor set
we saw the inverse where k27
trimethylation was low and double strand
rna
was high so
this may suggest that there are
potentially prostate cancer
cancer patients out there that could
have a hot tumor and potentially
responsive
to checkpoint blockade therapy
or the fact that we just don't have
enough
heat if you will switched on and so by
using epigenetic therapy we may
positively affect both of these types of
populations
so trying to find out where our whole
viral mimicry or double-stranded rna
species were coming from
um
we again and unfortunately this this
actually was a question from from a
reviewer at the time and under covert
conditions
we couldn't uh actually do in the lab
and do the experiments but luckily
enough there was a data set out there uh
from jindan news lab in chicago where
she had used ellen cap an ellen cap
human prostate cancer cell line
and she used hair pins
to knock down easy h2 versus first the
hairpin control
and so what we firstly saw here which
was a nice control compared to the
prostatectomy samples that i showed you
earlier is that our 97 gene list of
interferon stimulated genes was not
associated with any enrichment of the
k27 trimethyl mark but again they were
mostly associated with a k27 acetylation
or active mark upon easy h2
knock down we got more enrichment or an
increased enrichment which went along
with what we're describing as activation
or transcriptional activation following
easy h2 inhibition
now in collaboration uh with with david
labay a a friend from uh we both met at
dana father he's now uh running his own
lap up in montreal
um he used his um a bioinformatics
pipeline that that he has in his lab
where basically we wanted to use this
chip seek data to ask
genes that had um
endogenous retroviruses housed in their
three prime utr
and what genes
lost of those genes lost
k27 trimethylation with the concurrent
gain of k27 acetylation at the time of
easy h2 knockdown we came to a
conclusion of 302 genes that were
under this
this this cut-off and those are actually
in the supplement data of our paper
and just showing you the the summation
of this as to where we take these 302
genes and we look uh here to where we
get a loss of k27 trimethyl here in the
blue line following easy h2 knockdown
with an overall concurrent gain of k27
acetyl indicating activation so this all
fit the bill that we were indirectly
targeting these gene well sorry i should
say directly targeting these genes to
induce a viral mimicry response through
the release of three prime utr housed
endogenous retroviruses
and thus indirectly getting
the interferon stimulated genes that
were enriched in our original rna-seq
data
so coming to this we sort of wanted to
uh work out um mechanistically who was a
middle man we focused in on sting uh
just because of a
potential therapeutic interest with
sting and then when we looked at our
data sets just correlation data here of
sting expression against our easy h2
activity score we can actually see here
that
the activity score is from left to right
easy h2 high activity to easy h2 low
activity and so as you can see as the
activity becomes lower from left to
right we get more sting expression so we
had a positive correlation here with low
activity and overall sting
expression we also saw uh the same for
rig eye and some other
sensors
in this in this family
now functionally we came in with our two
mouse cell lines that we use in the lab
prostate cancer cell lines
that are derived from the genetically
engineered mouse models where p10 is
knocked out or as i've already
introduced cmic is over expressed now
these run a black six
background which will be important uh
for for another experiment coming up but
as you can see here when we did uh we
performed chemical inhibition of sting
we didn't lose the induction of double
strand rna so sting is obviously down
downstream of the double strand rna
because it has to sense it so that made
sense but what we lost was two critical
uh interferon stimulated genes now these
are by flow cytometry so this is protein
levels here but we lost tumor expression
of pdl one and also the potential for
tumor expression of mhc class one so
again
um you know preventing the potential for
antigen presentation
uh we also uh double doubled up on this
with genetic validation of sting using
crispr
and when we crisp it out sting of these
cells we basically saw the same response
as as you can see here so sting was an
important mediator for this
for the cell to upregulate into
interferon stimulated genes
so in vivo
and again using our cmic
high mech transplant model in uh in
black six mice
you can firstly see that our
tumors here are both resistant to pdl
pd-1 antibody sorry and the episode
compound are the easy h2 inhibitor
now these tumors grow quite rapidly as
you can see as we reach a
an ethical endpoint here of around 18 to
20 days usually
but when we combine the two
therapies we could see that we got quite
a a significant slowdown of tumor growth
now this wasn't a stop but slowing this
tumor down the way that we did was it
was a pretty big statement for this
model so we were very happy with this
having a focus on tumor pdl1 levels
at the time of this study
we also
performed on our tumors we did cd45
sorting and on our cd45 negative cells
which is which is basically the tumor
cells we could see that the tumor cells
did have an up regulation of pdl1 uh in
response to the uh epigenetic therapy or
ezh2 inhibition
we also confirmed this in our two
organoid models the top level being
transcription
here so with uh both easy h2 inhibitors
we got a nice transcriptional up
regulation as expected as it was one of
the interferon stimulated genes in our
data set
and at the protein level as well where
we've got quite a nice upregulation in
both our systems
so with pd pdl1 upregulation we wanted
to functionally validate this as well
and this is where the the strain
of the of the cells the mouse cells that
we use here
are critical again our prostate cancer
models are from a black six strain and
this is a cytotoxic assay where we rely
on an mhc class mismatch and an immune
cytotoxicity by incubating them or
calculating them with
fvb splenocytes
so just to give you an indication here
our background
cytotoxicity after four hours of
co-incubation
is represented here by the white bars
now when we pre-treat these tumor cells
with easy h2 inhibitor and up regulating
pdl1 we can see that we
induce a protective
protection against the cytotoxicity here
and then when we introduce an antibody a
pd-1
antibody we break this protection and we
get back or rescue our
cytotoxicity of this of the splenocytes
or induced by the splenocytes
when we crispr out pdl1 in these cells
we can see that we ablate all this
there's there's no protection here
represented by these two bars and again
no significant increase or or
recapturing that the cytotoxicity as
expected
we again validated this in our second
model the p10 knockout model again on a
black six background and incubated with
fvb splenocytes
again our l
control kill here
went once co-incubated we see the
protection and we see the rescue of
cytotoxicity and again crispering our
pdl1 in these cells we also ablate that
showing this is pdl one dependent um uh
protection here that that we are
inducing with easy h2 in inhibition
so just to give you an idea of just the
tumor micro environment and i'm really
just showing here that the two biggest
sort of movers were both our t cell
populations where we increased our
overall tumor infiltrate both with easy
h2 and combo more so with cd4 and cd8
cells
um
we also moved
and reprogrammed we think uh the the
tumor-associated macrophages where we
had um ios positive uh m1 teams here
being increased by both combo and epz
uh easy h2 inhibition
overall we get down to combo we get our
biggest loss of arjun positive m2 tams
and of course the ratio here is greater
m1 to m2 in our combo so we think we're
getting a little change in the paradigm
there
with suppressing our uh
our immunosuppressive tams and gaining
our cytotoxic t cells
with with our anti-tumor tams as well
the m1 tams now looking at the cd4 cd8
subsets we can see here that we don't
actually activate here looking at 41b bb
as a as an activation marker of t cells
we can see that we don't affect the cd4
positive cells
but we also don't see a pedia pd1 shift
on these cells
but in the cd8 population as expected
with a pd-1 inhibitor we do
see activation of these cells both in
pd-1 and combo arms and also easy h2
inhibition does down regulate not
significant but down regulates pd-1 on
these t-cells
so that overall just gives you a summary
of the story now what's exciting
just been funded
by
epizyme to conduct a phase two trial a
neo-adjuvant study where we will
pre-treat um
uh patients with the easy h2 inhibitor
before prostatectomy and this is to
provide a proof of concept that indeed
easy h2 inhibition can heat up
uh the um the the prostate uh tumors
adequately to where we can then
hopefully move on to a combination uh
study in in patients
so
um i'll just point out these two papers
for the full story published last
december and in march of this year uh
these this is just a summary um of this
work and this but these two papers give
you the full store and just want to
thank
really an army of people here that have
helped me over the years but also helped
me uh with with my recent move to see
the sinai from dana farber
and also my new lab members and also
catherine and debbie who really
spearheaded a lot of the work
catherine's a postdoc debbie's a
scientist but uh these two ladies really
spearheaded a lot of the work that's
coming out of my lab as of late and so a
big thanks to all them
the fellow faculty and also the
collaborators and thank you again for
your attention and happy to take any
questions